welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania's biggest swing is the
character of Modoc mechanized organism
designed only for killing whom early
trailers revealed to be the return of
Darren cross Corey stole yellowjacket
from the 2015 Ant-Man film last seen
with his body parts shrinking out of
proportion but in this Movie Spoiler
warning for the more specific plot
details ahead Darren reveals that his
disfigured body was found by Kang's
forces and rebuilt into this weapon with
a soggy little but Modoc in his visual
appearance his whole journey his
inclusion in this film has been one of
the more divisive aspects of quantumania
and I totally get it but I really don't
mind Corey stole's performance and I'd
rather like his campy but wholesome it's
never too late to stop being a dick
moral that this character becomes a
vehicle of yet Modoc seems to be the
latest example of what critics call The
Uncanny Valley of characters created by
animation or visual effects in which the
more lifelike a designer tries to make a
character that we know is simulated the
more our brains disassociate from their
faces and see them as soulless and
creepy this idea of The Uncanny Valley
has been thrown around a lot lately when
it comes to the BFF titles like She-Hulk
I didn't always agree but in this case
there are definitely some deeper issues
going on with Modoc that I think we
should dig into and I'm not alone on
this because I have now seen guanamania
three times in theaters and I'm pretty
sure that Marvel Studios actually
updated the bfx between screenings
something they have admitted to doing
before and have definitely been caught
doing on Disney plus now the day before
the release guanamania screenwriter Jeff
loveness tweeted some behind the scenes
photos that included a life-size
sculpture that the production used as a
stand-in for Modoc this gives us a
decent parameter of what the production
was aiming for when it comes to Modoc
but more importantly what the other
actors were seeing when they performed
their reaction shots and that's
extremely significant because the
uncanny valley isn't about one isolated
still or clip of a CGI face shared on
another social media platform despite
what haters on Twitter want you to think
it is about the context of the scene
every movie has VFX that artists
consider unfinished but what matters is
does it work in the context of the
live-action elements of the scene when
characters like Scott or Cassie or Hank
cringe upon scene Darren's big face are
they cringing at the same Darren face
that we are the reaction shots are
arguably more important because these
actors are audience surrogates if they
buy it we'll buy it and we are really
good [__] detectors when it comes to
whether or not live action actors
actually buy something and already with
this statue you can see that the
proportions of Darren's face used on set
are not really the same as the finished
product his nose is a lot smaller his
brow is thicker and heavier making his
bulging eyes look more sunken in his
face the theatrical rendering of Modoc
looks a lot more like Corey stole it
keeps his nose a certain size but still
enlarges his eyes and stretches out his
mouth yet Corey stole's voice sounds
exactly the same which kind of throws us
off part of the reason we're willing to
accept Josh Brolin's face is Thanos or
Mark ruffalo's faces Hulk is that those
designers constructed entirely new
skulls using the bone structure of the
actors faces and puts a lot of
musculature and scarring and other skin
textures on top of those faces and yeah
makes their faces a new color which
isn't just a comic book thing it's
really important because we need to
distance associate a little bit from the
actor but here with Modoc it's really
just Corey stahl's flesh colored head on
a tiny body with his eyes and mouth just
a little bit bigger than they should be
and I do think Marvel might have been
doing some between screening adjustments
to Modoc based on the height of his
forehead and his eyebrows and this image
compared to the height of his eyebrows
in this image in the later image it
definitely looks like modok's face was
given more detail more wrinkles better
to find crow's feet and a five o'clock
shadow it looks more photorealistic but
as is often the case in the uncami
valley that's not always a good thing
the thing to notice about loveness is
Modoc statue is that we can clearly see
its three-dimensional shape in Quantum
medium Modoc is often framed direct to
camera only in rare examples do we see
him in profile framing Modoc direct to
camera flattens his face and makes it
look like his features are being
projected on the screen which is why on
social media you're seeing some people
compare him to George Lopez and Spy Kids
3D and today's video is sponsored by
Babel one of the top language learning
apps in the world new year new rock
stars we're expanding even Beyond The
Deep dive if I want to reach a new
audience I need to speak speak a new
language which is where Babel comes in
Babel specializes in preparing you for
real life encounters and situations
Studies have shown that 15 hours of
using Babel is the equivalent of a
semester of college Spanish and 15 hours
at Babel flies by like nothing I can
watch videos listen to podcasts play
games or do lessons whatever kind of
learning mood I'm in Babel's got
something that fits the bill I love how
they gamify learning I have daily goals
and achievements I can unlock as I learn
the language now I'm pretty early in my
battle Journey but I have started to
learn some useful phrases like
I said I'm early at this my
pronunciation's awful I know I'm working
on it but Babel is so patient with me
get up to 60 off your subscription when
you click the link in the description or
scan the QR to start learning with Babel
today now film directors sometimes
Center their characters and have them
look directly into the lens to go for a
more comedic effect like Wes Anderson
uses this framing a lotiti used it and
throw a Ragnarok insane where Valkyrie
is talking to Thor and Bruce but when
characters look directly at the camera
the eye contact by Design takes us out
of the moment it screams listen to me
audience and it is exactly why us
YouTubers frame ourselves
presentationally like this alternatively
in cinema the common representational
Framing and narrative moments frames
characters looking off camera it's more
of a vanity angle designed to trick you
into seeing the subject as more
attractive than it actually is and
parasocially linking your empathy with
this artificial facade so we got listen
to me audience and look at me viewer
which is why I think as quantomania goes
on we start to feel some artificial
sympathy for Modoc after Cassie knocks
him out he even says the words look at
me I'm such a dick when he jams his face
into Kang's force field it's among the
best he looks in the whole movie it's
clear the artists prioritize these
close-ups at the top of their list and
then as he dies but in a vomit we see
him from the side and you know what it
works he looks pretty good the cuts and
the bruises all over his face just gives
it enough detail and renders it a
different shade making him look not at
all like Corey stole anymore but his own
thing and perhaps most importantly here
his crown headpiece is broken so it no
longer looks like his face is framed in
a spy kid's frame but is rather just an
enlarged dying head and while I think
this is definitely enough to Escape The
Uncanny Valley I must admit that we're
still a bit unsure whether to laugh or
to cry in this moment maybe both but
because this movie made Modoc out of
Darren cross a human we once knew we
just struggled to make the psychological
leap of seeing him as the comedic
character Modoc is best known as I would
argue that had Marvel brought in a
different actor to play a version of
Modoc more true to the George Tarleton
comic origin even a well-known actor we
could have better gotten on board with
the over-the-top nature of the character
but we already know Darren has something
else in the MCU who's a scary awesome
performance that I really liked in Modoc
for people who know and love him from
the comics really just needs to be his
own thing but what do you think is
everyone being too hard on Modoc by the
way I love doing this kind of deeper
analysis in the movies that aims not to
just be knee-jerk hate on them to get to
the deeper Roots why things are the way
they are and over on new Rockstar's
second Channel The Deep dive I'm
actually thinking about doing a fuller
investigation into other times Marvel
has snuck in bfx updates under our noses
like this let me know if you'd be
interested in that And subscribe at Deep
dive NR and you can support our Network
by getting something over at nerd
riot.shop or merch partner something
like what I'm wearing from the deep dive
collection with our little osmanat guy
on there you can follow me on social
media at eavos follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
foreign